Pierre-Jacques Depallens, 55 ans,
je suis médecin psychiatre installé à Toulon
et je suis adhérent au MoDem depuis 2004.
J’ai beaucoup fait dans l'associatif étudiant
quand j’étais jeune avec les corpos à Marseille,
parce que j'ai fait des études de médecine,
les mutuelles étudiantes, etc.
Et puis en 2003 - 2004,
après le discours de Bayrou de Toulouse,
j'ai décidé d'adhérer au Mouvement Démocrate.
Je suis élu à Toulon, au Conseil municipal de Toulon
qui est sous les feux de la rampe actuellement,
avec la démission du maire par les juges.
C'est le troisième maire sur quatre
qui est condamné à Toulon depuis 1959.
Et on a une particularité aussi,
c'est qu'on a eu le troisième président du Conseil Général
sur quatre qui a été inculpé aussi.
On est dans le cadre d'une liste d'union
avec les amis d’En Marche, les autres démocrates et les centristes du Var.
Donc, on est dans l'opposition
à l'ancien maire Hubert Falco.
C'est le discours de Toulouse qui m'a déclenché.
Quand j'ai entendu François Bayrou
aller tout seul devant tout le monde.
Et dire que si on pensait tous la même chose,
c'est qu'on pensait plus rien.
Présentateur : Et tout est fait pour organiser un accueil chaleureux,
à défaut d'être toujours sincère,
à celui qui vient pourtant dénoncer l'hégémonisme
d'un parti unique réuni derrière un seul homme.
François Bayrou : Si nous pensons tous la même chose,
c'est que nous ne pensons plus rien.
Alors il y a des lieux... *Sifflements*
Ça m'a fait un électrochoc.
C'est exactement ce que je pensais
du rassemblement de l'UMP de l'époque.